i'm funny right now i think he's funny
yeah now like growing up we've talked
about this he wasn't funny growing up he
wasn't a funny dad no so he didn't bring
it home
no the humor the the energy no
because your early stuff is so pat is so
full of and energy is the word and i
also wasn't allowed to see your stand up
when i was younger too when i was let's
put up some early how he made it i was
watching some before you know preparing
for this and i
when i was growing up you were waiting
you're prepared
i mean i i
yeah i just wanted to watch other young
clips because when i was growing up i
remember like of course it was the
classic
the glove on the head was like one of
the first stand-up things i remember
like so i've told this many times but
the truth of the matter is i went up on
a dare
you know oh wow and that was just fear
and i thought the joke was gonna be
they said you should get up on stage i'm
not a [ __ ] comedian i'm gonna get i
thought the joke i didn't think things
through was somebody was going to go
ladies and gentlemen howie mandel the
[ __ ] is howie man
that's that's the joke right ladies and
gentlemen joe schmoe and i was going to
walk up and then in that moment after i
walked up i noticed people sitting there
waiting
and out of that came
pure fear instinct an instinct right and
i went okay okay okay okay all right
okay okay
all right and they started giggling at
the okay and i went what what
i also put my hands in my pocket and i
uh you probably know i have ocd yeah
and i carried rubber gloves with me
because i know when i was out i would
have to go to a public restroom oh wow
so that's going down
and then i go okay okay and i just
pulled it over my head and i started
breathing and they started laughing as
the fingers were going up and then i
blew it up the first time the first time
and i went and i went good night wow get
out of there and the guy went you got to
come back tomorrow what do i do he goes
do the same thing i did nothing
i did nothing and my whole act was based
on nothing yeah which i thought was a
joke and steve martin was one of my
favorite
comedians of all time at the time before
i watched richard pryor work because the
joke
that i
related to was he was joking about bad
jokes yeah like the wild and crazy guy
the guy with that
i think what happens is you have to if
you are talking to an audience that is a
frame of reference for culture or for
maybe in pop culture or like just life
uh
then you can make those kinds of jokes
because it's like we've been we've been
oversaturated with
with humor with jokes so we get it
already now we can make fun of that
stuff right can we well somehow not now
we may be right now right now
i'm feeling there are so many and that's
why i look i understand i do a bad
stand-up character uh if you put in an
evening with tim hydeca real quick just
to show you what it looks like
and you will see what an [ __ ] should
become very quickly watch the trailer or
the trailer i don't know but is it the
trailer i mean you can just put the
whole thing on and just just let it skip
anywhere but
uh is this a bad guy
and
lately i've been doing the act right
come out but you're using your real name
so do people know that you're doing a
character or do they think of you they
uh figure it out eventually usually
i used to do it in front of
unsuspecting audiences and they would
you know be very uncomfortable because
and that wasn't that great and it was
fun
but it is also fun to get laughs too you
know
so i love having both i love games
i can take it down because when i say
tna i'm talking about
token and ale so
so it looks like a stand-up
set and i'd be right what else i love
food as everybody here i mean i love
food i love them i guess i'm a foodie i
don't know
i'm a foodie
sue me i'm a foodie i uh there's one
joke here i said to my friend and he
said you got to use this in the show i
said um
i said
if i ever get to go to another planet
right i said if i ever get to go to
another planet
uh i will not be saying take me to your
leader right you see that in the movies
take me to your leader uh i'll be saying
take me to your sushi
that's what a foodie i am sucks
uh oh my god i gotta watch this yeah
netflix do transform no it's just on
youtube it's on youtube a little more
perennial youtube
now that don't watch the places
um but anyways
no netflix and all those people said uh
uh
you're a funny guy but it feels like
you're making fun of comedy
you're making fun of comedy now you guys
doesn't make sense you gotta be careful
with that because you can't make fun of
comedy's sacred
know you making fun of comedy comedy is
we
you
a serious series
serious
children could die yeah
that's good
amazing i will love it i already love it
just with that one joke but you know
it's it's so sad
get that face off the screen please i
can't take it you just don't like the
screen
[Laughter]
um the the thing that i that is amazing
is that kind of commitment
to a character or to a vibe that you
want to create and i love everybody that
works with me knows i love
it's always somebody around me that says
it's enough already howie that you got
to break that tension right and
because i'm locked into network tv and
whatever else i'm doing i have to do it
like behind the scenes and it's always
my
that's why i live you guys are like a
dream and and and i really as much as i
i didn't know who you were i love
no i mean they're easy to like right
away right no but not but now that i
realize you are the guys behind that
work and those cuts and what you're
doing you're [ __ ] brilliant you're
like conductors of comedy of great
comedy well i'm the conductor they're
the uh oboe players
no you're like the musician yeah
you're like playing it and i'm the
soloist up front we're the composers no
wait a minute now composing easy
[Music]